hello everyone it is time to check out a
new super massive game i am always
excited and usually when i start these
uh first hour looks where i just like
jump into the first hour of a game and
for the record if you guys enjoy this
i'll probably continue doing this one as
a series like i did with the last dark
pictures anthology entry but usually i
just like jump right into the game
this menu is really cool
like they've gone very retro aesthetic
with it which i think suits the idea
that this game is going to be a little
bit more comedic than their previous
releases um but i'm excited about it for
anyone who doesn't know
uh same creators as until dawn
it's very like teenage horror slasher
film inspired um
it's kind of the stuff that they make so
yeah this is their latest entry
published by 2k very big thank you to 2k
for giving me a code not sponsored they
just gave me a code so i could play it
early it comes out tonight
and i am excited these are
so fun to play um unfortunately having
to play this one during the day just
because of my schedule this week
and we know nights free
which feels wrong
and i'm also playing it on streamer mode
by the way
which means that there may be uh
licensed music that i'm not getting
which does obviously change your
experience but
so that youtube doesn't get mad at me
it's always a good start when we start
with a car through the woods
i might need to turn my lights off
[Music]
let's get a bit of glare
[Music]
are we seeing the perspective of a
monster here
[Music]
we
cause of are
stories
[Music]
[Music]
it's always exciting to be like ooh
what's our new big bad guy gonna be
who are they what are they about
i look forward to finding out
[Music]
i'm covering like a lot of text over
here
i'm just gonna move to the other side
why'd you kill the music i think you
know why um
i don't think i do me up here it begins
with an l figure it out like the l word
lesbians
lost max we're lost we're just we're in
geographic flux right so
lost
that's debatable
hmm
[Music]
whoa this is new
they've never done anything like this
before how cool i'm going to consider
the following as it will guide you
through the various twists and turns
that may appear during your stay at
hackett's quarry okay what you see here
are quick time events or qtvs which will
help you to act at just the right time
watch your step
packets very
um twilight zone attention to your
surroundings
take your eye off the ball
and it could spell disaster
the path you tread
but that doesn't mean there won't be
obstacles along the way
interesting okay
what is it up i just swipe up yeah honey
nice catch
okay
thank you
man the roads are definitely getting
worse out here okay so they're dating
the rustic summer camp experience oh
right that's where we're going i lost
track like 200 miles ago 200 miles ago
huh
you know what max it's okay it doesn't
make you any less of a man you know if
columbus hadn't gotten lost and landed
on these golden shores no way to put my
webcam in america because i'm cutting
his face off now too here apple pie here
columbus never actually landed in north
america
what are you talking about
didn't even know he wasn't in asia are
you serious
just another guy who didn't want to
admit he was lost well just another guy
who's got a whole day named after him so
put that in your pipe and smoke it oh my
god okay just get us to camp already
before i roll my eyes out of my head
please i'm working on it i'm working on
it
it is very dark do you guys have any
lights on at all
oh uh
map
voila
what is that
yeah yeah no but seriously hun what
happened to the the normal map this is
the normal map the one on the phone
no bars
of course not it's a weird thing to say
it's a normal map no balls you can look
let's see so we are
well i guess they don't put summer camps
on maps
have you seen any signs for it
look at the road dude
hey eyes on the road thank you
oh no
i'm glad i didn't miss it whoa what the
[ __ ] was that
did y'all just see the
person sitting in the back seat
did i see that right
i think i saw it twice like a
old lady
are you okay
yeah yeah
i mean
still in one piece jesus christ yeah i
cannot see super well up there
what uh no no max i wasn't a bear i
don't know what it was either i think it
was a person
no i'd look like an animal to me
do you think we hit a person
i don't know
well you didn't hit him did you i mean
it was really close like really close
but maybe we didn't
check the front of the car
uh i've never played a game this dark
this early
she's giving me glare
yeah if you have blood on the front of
your car then you hit somebody [ __ ]
what is it
i really have this car up
well yeah
well maybe it looks worse than it is
uh
i should check out the damage before we
try to start it up again huh could you
grab my uh he looks like kyle
rittenhouse it's really bothering me he
looks like kyle rittenhouse
and i caught unsee it i was like he
looks like somebody
maybe it's the glass
oh no
oh no
[Music]
it's not so bad
my mom's gonna kill me
okay controls are a little bit odd maybe
this is better played with a controller
obviously i'm playing on pc
that's fine i don't have anything else
to do
max brinley rejected from landis
university
okay well i wouldn't have looked at that
if i knew that's what snoop meant
thanks honey
yeah
do you need a hand yeah actually if you
could just shine a light right here
there you go perfect it doesn't look
like this blood on the front of the car
maybe you didn't kill anybody get out of
here the better just picture yourself
curling up in front of a big old fire
pit singing campfire sing-alongs i don't
think people curl up right in front of
big old fire pits why not
they don't want to catch on fire
pretty authentically written like i do
feel like they do a good job
the cheesy teens
um
is that the old lady who i swear i saw
in the car
where you going
just over here
just
stay there for a second okay i'm almost
done
um
hurry up
god max hurry up i wouldn't have said
either of those things but i'm not her
what's going on i'm worried that there's
somebody down there
are you serious
yeah
they could be hurt i don't know i didn't
think we actually hit anything well i
don't know i just i heard something okay
like a woman
do you think we hit her i'd definitely
be hearing [ __ ] i just want to check it
out okay
all right
just don't go too far okay be careful
yeah
this seems like a bad idea
i i just want you to know that i the
player do not agree with your decision
to do this at all
i think that you should stay with the
cop this is insane
i would never do this walk alone in the
woods
that's how girls end up dead
absolutely not
your boyfriend also sucks for not being
like hell no [ __ ]
you gonna die okay i do need to just up
the brightness a tiny bit
um oh i should also look through this
anyway
none yet clues none yet
evidence none yet laura investigate
northern woods camp
what's that
huh
maybe maybe i need to go to main menu to
do it so i will not make you guys look
at that
i'll just make sure i fix it for the
next one or again play at night time
okay
the fool i wonder who this is we all
know a fool when we see one don't we
innocence and freedom or recklessness
and risk taking spontaneity actions
without thought the consequences to
match think think and don't get burnt
yeah because usually like these cards um
are pretty relevant to a lot of the
stuff that happens and can like give you
hints for like people gonna die but this
one does feel different to a lot of
their other games so far i would say
oh yeah i'll also if i do another
episode i'll uh
oh this could be the woman in the car
i'll play with controller
make it a bit smoother
there was a poster for a traveling
sideshow ah that's who our villains are
gonna be
it looks like it's been here a while
i've forgotten in the woods are those
burn marks around the edges
that
is who it's gonna be
we're gonna get haunted wait what that's
just the same thing
um
buy tickets now
we're not back
keep hitting the wrong button back
so you're just looking for a woman you
think we hit this is so stupid i
hate you for this
this is just such a bad idea that i am
unwillingly going along with
you do not have my support i didn't
uh oh
oh no oh the vibes are bad
oh god
okay
i can't [ __ ] see [ __ ]
can you walk this way
this way
oh gosh
yeah the controls are definitely a bit
weird
is this the back the way i came i think
it might be right yeah i tried to go
down this way
it was followed
so we'll try and split
you'll be over here i think could be one
direction
what's she saying silas
well say less
say less bestie
oh god
the vibes are bad
she might die here you know
like i feel like the dark pictures once
started slowly but but
you ain't gonna play by the same rules
here
[Music]
that's so creepy
i hate it i hate it a lot i hate it so
much
oh god
where are you
in good news she's fine
she's not been hit by a car recently
that wasn't her
i'm very glad you aren't making me run
back because [ __ ] we i got lost as [ __ ]
and real fast
and i do not feel like i should be held
accountable
oh god
uh oh i don't know how i did that wrong
do i need to press s
i assumed it was click swipe down but
maybe not
it is okay it's that's w
yeah i'm not sure which keys they are
much better with a controller i think
somebody kept saying silas in my ear
no there's something out there like
there's
noises
take a few breaths just breathe just
breathe it's okay it's the woods there's
a lot of stuff out there it's easy to
freak yourself out listen especially if
you're hurt
can we just get out of here please of
course yeah yeah let's go let's go i
mean he seems nice
i still think he's a piece of [ __ ] for
letting you go out in the woods by
yourself
something's gonna happen something's
gonna happen something's gonna happen
nothing happened okay okay i was faked
out it's fine there we go turn like a
kid max come on here we go here we go
we're getting out of here
i'm sorry
that's okay it's okay game comes out um
thursday night i think
we're okay okay caught up to hotel we're
safe in the car really we're gonna be
okay
[ __ ]
oh my god my heart's the sheriff i think
that's how you know it because the music
yeah from the trailer how are you doing
this evening
are either of you injured no ah she
bumped her head well barely barely
bumped in i mean i can i can't even feel
it my bum not my head i'm fine really
we're fine we're just a little shaken up
[Music]
well you folks want to tell me what
happened here
okay sure
um
something jumped out evasive well
that's not honest something didn't jump
out but i'll tell the truth
we um some didn't jump out it looked
like someone's just on the road in front
of the car and we didn't want to hit it
so we swerved and
now here we are
something jumped out
that's believable deer exist
i again i also think it might have been
an animal okay
i'm sorry
i'm going with whatever she thinks is
honest and they were gone
they
ma'am did you hit someone no no god no
of course not
you know i mean i don't think so
bit of a weird performance sir
keep the car running the cop seems
anxious
is this kind of like the all-time
scariest kind
i don't know this is my first cop what
like ever uh yeah i'm not a criminal
huh
you know what i've actually never spoken
to a cop in the us
since i've been here eight years i've
never
like outside of ones that i've needed
for help
i've never been pulled over
now you folks want to tell me
just what in the hell you are doing all
the way out here this late at night
drugs
oh how did you go we're heading up to
hackett's quarry summer camp
we're new counselors
you're one night early no no we know um
but we figured we'd get in early and
scope it out you know they know we're
coming we called ahead
and to be honest sir one of us kind of
oversold their navigation skills and got
us completely lost
he is creepy you're not gonna make it
but it's also dark
not tonight
harbinger motel it's the nearest place
you can bunk up there for the night okay
uh i think we're just gonna stick to the
plan sir i mean mr hackett knows we're
coming and we called ahead no ma'am
you're gonna head to the harbinger motel
do you understand
oh
okay i'm gonna go insistent they'll do
respect sir why can't we go to hack it's
corey because i told you to go to the
motel
okay i just don't understand what the
problem i am please step out of the
vehicle i mean i would want to know why
they can't do that the cops can't do
that ma'am
if you wouldn't mind stepping out of the
vehicle i would just like to show you a
route on your map there
hmm son
remain in the vehicle
this cops on a bit of a power trip
okay
okay
so
we
not necessary to do that to a pencil not
necessary to do that together
harbinger motel literally no about zero
benefits here zero of benefit right okay
and where was hecatory again
well
i'm sure the fine folks
at the harbinger motel can guide you
there
first thing in the morning i get it
i would just tell her why i'd just be
like for your own safety it's raining
out you've just been in a car accident
you could have a concussion please go to
the hotel that would actually be
reasonable and fine just say that
[Music]
just say it
still please
how did he even find him i guess he
would have seen the broken part of the
road or whatever what are you doing
hold
still
[Music]
gonna check a head or something
um no i don't feel like i need a recoil
it's fine
yeah
i regret it i regret not recoiling
fresh is a daisy
you can return to vehicle ma'am
didn't like any of that
we didn't like it
harbinger
motel
again it's stay on the road not
unreasonable
just
explain why
yeah i'll have a look
good night you didn't want it down to
write down any of the details or
they may have hit someone
i'm not gonna tell you how to do your
job ooh pretty lighting
i think the cop is probably like
socially awkward but not actually a
villain that's what i'm gonna say 23
minutes into playing this game that's my
my guess
uncomfortable but not actually
villainous
why is this guy just sitting there
that guy was giving me major weirdos
they do needed like at least a dozen
showers oh my god i know what was up
with the thing
was it blood
oh yeah
meet
you man
i again i mean i think the hotel is a
good idea let's get back on the road yes
the shots are making me so [ __ ]
nervous
i agree so where's this motel okay so
we're here and the motel is here okay
but we're going here what's there
heck it's quarry
how'd you do that
i don't know i kind of tricked him into
showing very slick
are you sure we shouldn't just get to
the motel
just go to the motel honey you really
want to listen to the advice you just
had somebody told us in the middle of
the whisper into your ear creep ass
hotel in the woods no that sounds
terrible this i'm sorry
shall we that's what i thought ma'am
oh my god if he called me ma'am one more
time i was gonna shove that badge up his
dick
seriously do i look like a man to you
i've got like 20 years before i'm a man
what
20 is
debatable easy i mean i'm kind of into
mams
okay we're done here
the the shots just kept making me so
nervous that somebody was gonna just pop
up every [ __ ] second of that
my gosh
uh i think it was a bad call but
i guess if it wasn't that far
what difference does it make
laura is this someone new no you gotta
be kidding me there's nobody here his
name is [ __ ] can we just look around
before we jump to conclusions did you
actually even talk to mr hackett or did
you just leave a message what's the
difference this this is the difference
hello
i guess he doesn't check his voicemail
how was i supposed to know that
that's pretty stupid
i mean clearly there's somebody here
yeah or it's just an abandoned car and
this is a complete waste why would there
be an abandon i'll get the car
next come on
yeah you should have gone to the hotel
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
kyle ryden house over here has a point
this is stupid
i will also add subtitles if you do
another playthrough based on how
interested you guys are
i'll add subtitles make it a little bit
brighter
play with the controller fix some of the
issues i'm having
well there's a light on
right
or maybe i'm seeing narrow
oh i can't see
oh okay hang on this uh
uh
i can't see at all
um this way
uh
that is completely invisible to my eyes
so we're not gonna go that way because i
can't see
is it max playing music
pick up over here probably another card
oh it's a map
looks like a nice place
it doesn't kill you
make you stronger
fun
i forgot to put the s
will make you stronger oh did i miss
will that's on me
my bad
is this the abandoned car
no okay
hey you ready to roll
yes but only because i can't see i do
want to kind of scope this car out
see what's going on over here
it doesn't seem like i can inspect
really any part of it
nothing glowing
which means probably not
no it doesn't look like it
um
all right it's not gonna let me get in
the car wants me to do more
exploring okay
i feel like i can occasionally hear a
heartbeat and i don't know if that's
like a
cue for something that i'm missing
got spooky down here very fast
some sort of seller
girl if you even try to go in there you
are an idiot
[Music]
oh nice touch with the people
hey
hey are you okay
i'll be right back i'm gonna get some
help
you you go
girl cut
this level of bravery is unwarranted
let's get over here what's going on
there's somebody in the bunker i think
they might be stuck
stuck
is it mr hackett it looked like gollum
bring some tools so we can break the law
hey i'm back
we're gonna get you out of there
hey hey
wait what are these i don't know you
just said tools
why didn't you just bring
look there's someone in there
i like him
i'm not seeing anyone look i'm looking i
am
let me see
i want to like brace myself for a jump
scare but i can't because somebody could
die if i don't have my hands on this
keyboard someone there
okay okay so
well uh we think we do it with a hammer
hammer time you sure it's going to be
super loud that's also illegal
oh
yeah
yeah okay
wrenches
not that i feel like the noise is any
issue right now but we aren't urgent to
get whatever
because this isn't a real person this is
clearly a monster of some kind
also i don't think that's how that works
you need a hand yeah
okay
you see
you've seen evil death
i haven't
hello
i know i should it's on the list
are you hurt do you exist
hey
be careful
go with her
i feel like i changed my mind on this
bra every two seconds oh god
okay
we gotta scout that out
bloody color is it that maybe for a dog
cute a beauty give me any more but oh i
missed it
oh
oh my
did he leave
yikes
well um i just feel like we should go
back i feel like we should just leave
hon maybe it was a possum or something
no there was there was someone here i
swear you're not gonna tell them about
this hey
it's been kind of a night you know
let's just get to the motel we can come
back here first thing in the morning
yes
oh no i mean you must be exhausted
somebody's going to shut the door
i think our imagination
max
ah you hate to see it you hate to see it
oh my gosh
guess what
yeah
yeah it's a fair bit of blood but
from gollum
this is moving really quickly
this is kind of your fault
so
even if you die
fit on you
[Music]
oh that's a lot of blood yeah
i kind of feel like he's maybe not going
to be okay to drive
oh my
what ah
i was vouching for you just being creepy
and not actually a villain come on
look like the goddamn harbinger motel to
you
no
[Music]
and if i had had a choice
i would have i would have made them go
there
but i didn't have a say
[Music]
i feel
[Music]
is that the moon dog that's too big
i wonder who our protagonists will be
seems like they're
well neither of them are dead
no
max is probably dead he might not be
we didn't see him die so maybe you
should assume he's not
um i'm gonna leave it there because it
makes sense too
let me know if you want to see more of
the game huge thanks to 2k to
huge thanks to
2k4
giving me a code
yeah if we do another episode i'll make
sure i fix brightness and play with the
controller and uh
tinker with some settings
subtitles all that figure out where i
should put the webcam
i always want to go in authentic from
the jump so i don't want to do tests my
friend
i always want to do the show start yeah
just with genuine reactions
yeah
i've waited for you
she the one who's whispering yes
so i do hope our time together proves
enlightenment to the cutscene
there's no need to worry
i'm here to help you the eyes
yes
and terrifying
but
if you're brave enough
if you let me help you
i can help you
we can help each other
this is the card you found
the fool
i wonder who this is
we all know a fool when we see one don't
we
innocence and freedom or recklessness
and risk-taking i would say it's the
goal
this is a very cool performance and
don't get burnt
very impressive
um
well i wanted to stop but i don't want
to lose it so let's just like get
through this sequence then i suppose
um
and when it opens up in a gameplay again
as well i'll end
this is what might come to pass
a possible future
a path yet unchosen look here look here
because they have different versions of
this in the dark pictures anthology
well actually and in our tilde one
okay there are secrets out there you
know secrets and lies
paths to uncover
on which i can shed light
if you let me
help me help you
and remember
what doesn't kill you
will make you stronger
i just don't think that that's true
i think it's it's made up it's a myth
we have completed the prologue
i'm liking the tone
very fun
ladies peace and love the australian
yeah heck it's quiet forever
is that selena gomez
you know how many hearts are broken on
the last day of summer camp it's like a
romance apocalypse
uh
i think i can probably just not click
this and we'll leave it here so we get a
proper intro to these characters thank
you all for watching let me know if you
want to see more thank you to 2k for the
code i'll see you guys next time